[Musique]
républicaine martinique dans son crédit
se battent un bourgeon fred michel
terrot bonjour monsieur viol tombe on
joue aux auditeurs de martinique le
premier président de la fédération des
arts scéniques au projet de
reconstruction a donc été lancé par le
président du sénat gérard larcher
projets de reconstruction des
républicains qui rassemblerait la droite
et le centre
oui et puis nous avons un nouveau
président républicain depuis quelques
heures puisque jean leonetti un
remplacer l'eau en vo quai qui a
démissionné il ya 48 heures donc la
reconstruction est en marche est en
cours et puis nous avons beaucoup de
réserves dans notre partie puisque
autour de jean leonetti il y à françois
baroin il y à azaguié bien trop il y à
valérie pécresse
donc vous voyez que nous avons de la
réserve pour réorganiser notre parti
alors il ya nouveau président vous
l'avez dit me présenter les choses ainsi
lorsqu on dit qu'on veut travailler à un
projet qui rassemblerait la droite et le
centre est ce que quelque part ça ne
fait pas petit joueur
quand on sait que certains emmanuel
macron à lui lancé un projet qui a réuni
droite centre et gauche depuis deux ans
je ne sais pas ce que monsieur mac ont
fait moi ce que je remarque c'est que
notre famille politique a toujours été
les républicains ou ex ump a toujours
été un rassemblement de la droite et du
centre
mâcon lui il cherche à faire du
braconnage au sein de notre parti
politique aujourd'hui qui est ce qui le
président de la république en marche
personne ne le connaît qu'est-ce qui est
vice-président du parti la république en
marge personne ne le connaît la
république en marche rappelons le à 400
militants à jour de cotisation
chez nous nous sommes trois cent
cinquante mille donc on ne peut pas
comparer ce qui n'est pas comparable
donc laissé la république en marche là
où elle est elle essaie de faire du
braconnage au sein d'autres partis
politiques comme elle a commencé depuis
2010 est pour monsieur bouton vous êtes
un observateur attentif de la vie
politique il ne vous a pas échappé que
le premier ministre de la france sort de
nouveau oui le mil et à l'économie il
est la science de l'économie
mais ces quelques qui vient l'autre
parti politique ça veut dire que
monsieur macouin à part castaner
personne avec lui et c'est la raison
pour laquelle il essaie de chercher des
militants du parti présidentiel avec le
japon tensions les élections européennes
anti cernes ses recherches de bourges a
soit fred michel terrot non en tout cas
vous faites référence 1 à ces résultats
qui ont été mauvais nous ne le
contestons pas mais chaque élection est
différente
ouais les européennes ne sont pas les
présidentielles ne sont pas les
municipales je vais vous raconter une
petite anecdote j'ai rencontré un
électeur du front national qui m'a dit
où ça vous savez vraiment voter le pen
ont voté dans la peine aux européennes
jeudi mais non mélopées n'était pas
candidate au noir est bonne mais oui non
oui photo où il a enlevé bulletin le pen
n'était pas candidat de sa photo était
sur le bulletin m elle n'était pas sur
la liste
beaucoup de personnes pensent avoir
voter pour marine le pen les médias ont
focalisé entre le pen est ce la faute
des médias auraient alors que ni le pen
ni mcqueen était candidat en tout cas on
pensait en faisant dans votre conages ou
en communiquant avec des photos de
personnes qui sont pas candidates font
de meilleurs chiffres de saut
ça vous donne pas envie de vous remettre
en question la reconstruction du projet
politique des républicains s'est déjà en
cours ouais la ligne politique sera
réorganisée monsieur jean leonetti maire
d'antibes a repris les rênes du parti
c'est un homme on dirait qu'ils très
apprécié au sein du parti il saura faire
la synthèse avec tous ces dits de haut
pour pouvoir proposer comme l'a dit
gérard larcher hier président du sénat
une alternative crédible et clair pour
les français alors avant jean leonetti
aujourd'hui il ya eu ce donc cette
démission de laurent wauquiez
dimanche et quelques heures à pau
auparavant marion maréchal-le pen elle
avait de l'idée avait dans cette idée de
rapprochement rassemblement national l
air pour vous il faut il faut partir sur
cette base madame mary chain
le pen a abandonné la vie politique il
ya six mois elle n'a jamais dit qu'elle
revenait à la politique donc laisser
madame marion maréchal va bien là où
elle est bon la reconstruction des
républicains ici en martinique ça
pourrait donner crois mais n'y a pas de
problème de reconstruction et de
construction nous avons toujours été une
synthèse avec un parti puissant qui
compte 400 adhérents qui le dit partis
les plus importants à la martinique
donc il n'ya pas de reconstruction à
faire il y a simplement une continuation
de ce qui a été fait depuis pas mal
d'années c'est-à-dire une formation de
militants de telle sorte que nous soyons
prêts pour aller aux élections
municipales
sur le 2020 ce sera un bon troll de 2020
puisque nous avons des candidats qui
vont se présenter dans les différentes
municipalités l'objectif d'un parti
politique ce n'est pas seulement d'aller
aux élections mais c'est aussi de former
des militants ou qu'il prenne des
responsabilités et qu'il soit prêt au
moment où ils vont assumer ses
responsabilités donc il ya tout un
travail de formation qui est en train
d'être faits nous avons une équipe très
dynamique très jeune à la tête de
laquelle nous avons edith ville ayew
dont nous avons un comité qui a donné
les orientations récentes qu'on ne peut
pas dévoiler ici pour les prochaines
municipales
et puis déjà aussi pour les
territoriales de 2021 vous avez vu qu'au
cours des dernières heures des derniers
jours des dernières semaines y ait quand
même cette bataille de ténors de la
droite entre yan monplaisir et miguel
laventure ça vous fait quoi
tout cela est ce que ça peut nuire à
votre image de marque de 2-2 de
militants de droite de façon plus
globale plus large j'ai effectivement
entendu que mon plaisir tant pis
laventure sur vos autres olala ça c'est
joli mais ça fait beaucoup
d'éclaboussures de la mousse et de l'eau
mais nous avons crise et nous avons pris
très tôt nos distances avec ce groupe
bah payant chance ici même j'ai rappelé
que les membres de ce groupe de quatre
ou cinq jeux ne sont pas dans notre
famille politique donc nous avons pris
nos distances donc c'est regrettable
qu'ils règlent leurs comptes devant les
médias
on pouvait attendre une autre attitude
de gens qui se disent responsables et
qu'ils se disent mur vu leur âge en tout
cas
mais nous aux républicains nous sommes
très loin de ses éclaboussures i 2 c est
quand il leur appartient à eux de régler
en interne ce problème ce sont des
personnels et des personnalités sur
lesquelles vous ne voulez plus compté
pour les prochaines échéances monsieur
viol ton les membres de ba payant chance
vous avez dit tout à l'heure on l'a dit
dans l'éditorial qu'il était de droite
moi je ne le sais pas je ne le crois pas
où il avait fréquenté suffisamment pour
savoir si l'on est il de droite ce que
je dis c'est que je constate que bas
payés en chance est un groupe plutôt du
côté de en marche
ils ont fait ouvertement campagne pour
en marche il certains sont en marche
d'autres sont en démarche d'ailleurs
mais ils ne sont pas à droite donc il
faut leur poser la question de savoir où
ils sont mais moi je qualifie le groupe
bat péan chances de doper ni d'objets
politique non identifié
donc je ne vous permet pas de dire
aujourd'hui que cet opni cet objet
politique non identifié est de droite
photo michel terrot président des
républicains section martinique vous
êtes sensible à ce qui se passe en
martinique à cette montée de la violence
circulation d'armes à feu des tirs des
personnes qui malheureusement sont
victimes de deux balles perdues ça vous
effraie tout cela c'est vrai que nous
avons une montée nous remonter une
recrudescence de la violence ces
derniers temps même si quand on regarde
les chiffres au niveau national nous
restons quand même en deçà des problèmes
de violence et de délinquance
mais c'est vrai que il faudrait que les
élus toute la population parce que l'on
fait souvent posées sur les élus la
responsabilité de tout un airplay c'est
la faute des élus n'y a pas
d'électricité c'est la faute des élus on
entend souvent sous sous vos médias les
coups de gueule mais c'est un travail
que tout le monde doit faire ensemble
des associations les éducateurs
l'éducation nationale pour sensibiliser
la population dès le plus jeune âge de
justement de d'éviter de tomber dans ces
travers
c'est au travail c'est un travail de
tous et de chacun
un maire comme vous mr du saint-esprit
qui sera bientôt en fête le week-end
prochain
est-ce que vous pouvez demander par
exemple aux autorités d'intervenir pour
lutter contre cette montée de la
délinquance le maire est un pilier
central
la lutte contre la délinquance la
prévention de la délinquance d'ailleurs
et il lui appartient effectivement avec
d'autres avec le préfet avec le
sous-préfet que les autorités policières
et la gendarmerie de prévenir de non
seulement de sanctionner mais également
de faire de la prévention
il appartient au maire de coordonner un
peu toutes ces opérations de telle sorte
que la sécurité soit assurée parce que
la sécurité c'est la première liberté
des citoyens et c'est notre rôle à nous
les maires de veiller à ce que la
sécurité soit assurée et au delà de cela
est ce que les chefs de partis
pourraient par exemple parler d'une même
voix ils demandent aux autorités qu'ils
aient plus de moyens pour combattre
cette délinquance c'est ce qui est déjà
fait c'est ce qui est déjà fait vous
avez remarqué que beaucoup de communes
dont la nôtre au saint-esprit ont
installé la vidéoprotection ce qui
permet de baisser les taux de
délinquance
en tout cas cet esprit nous avons eu de
très bons résultats puisque la
délinquance se trouve à des niveaux
relativement bas mais il faut poursuivre
nos efforts et tous les maires de la
martinique font ce travail et la
vidéoprotection en train de s'installer
un peu partout ce qui rassure aussi les
administrés puisque il ya de la violence
mais aussi le sentiment d'insécurité qui
très fort à la menthe hic est qu'il faut
combattre
merci d'avoir été se bat avec nos frais
de celle ci on rappelle que vous êtes
président de la section martiniquaise
des républicains bonne journée à vous
remercier un coup